um Tiffany can I just say when you peed
off a zip line in girls trip it was
brilliant
oh my god Maya when you took a Dookie in
the street and bridesmaid it changed my
life it was inspiring thank you thank
you and look where we are now yeah and
now here are the nominees for Best live
action short film to cab elementary read
Van Dyke the 11 o'clock
Darren seal and Josh Lawson my nephew
Emmet Kevin Wilson jr. the silent child
Chris Overton and Rachel Shenton
what - what a all of us cuts yep been
rot and Tobias Rosen and the Oscar goes
to the silent child Chris Overton and
Rachel senses
[Applause]
nomination for Chris Overton and Rachel
Shenzhen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh god hello and I made a promise to our
six-year-old lead actress that I'd sign
this speech
my hands are shaking a little bit so I
apologize and our movie is about a deaf
child being born into a world of silence
it's not exaggerated or sensationalized
for the movie this is happening millions
of children all over the world live in
silence and face communication barriers
and particularly access to education so
deafness is a silent disability you
can't see it and it's not
life-threatening so I want to say the
biggest of thank yous to the Academy for
allowing us to put this in front of a
mainstream audience this is such a team
effort so I've got to say thank you to
our parents for making and selling
cupcakes so we could yeah for finishing
helping us finish the film thanks
everyone who backed our IndieGoGo
campaign Thank You Vanessa Johnston
Terry Murphy all our executive producers
Daniel murad everyone it's lecturers and
slick films all our incredible cast and
crew Maisy sly
Julie for Rebecca Harris Ali Farahani we
couldn't do without you but lastly my
fiancee Rachel Shenton it's really all
hard work for the last 12 years
really made this project authentic thank
you so much
[Applause]